Helpsters, our goal is to hand out
a frozen freeze pops to cool down the neighborhood.
Now who's got an idea?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah?
We want the neighborhood to know we have freeze pops,
so we should tell the neighborhood
we have freeze pops.
But what if you cannot hear us?
You know, mother Primm always says
to speak softly and carry a big megaphone.
[DING]
Use a megaphone to make our voices louder.
If we are going to give out freeze pops,
we need freeze pops, right?
Yeah, we do.
And that's job two, make freeze pops.
[DING]
So how do we stop the freeze pops from melting
before we hand them out?
That is job three.
[DING]
Find a way to keep the freeze pops cold.
I shall find a megaphone to make our voices louder.
Hm.
I'll make the freeze pops.
And I will find a way to keep them cold.
Fantastic.
Well, looks like everything's going great.
Nothing's going great.
What do you mean, Mr. Primm?
I went to the megaphone room to get a megaphone,
but when I got there, it was empty except for this.
Oh, huh, no megaphones.
Mm-hm.
No problem.
We'll just make a new megaphone.
With what?
Well, with the paper in your hand, you know, the sign.
Hm?
Just follow my commands, OK?
OK.
First, roll the paper into a cone.
All right?
OK, and next, tape the edges together.
All right.
Just use that tape the megaphones use
to hang up the sign, right?
What a lovely idea, yes.
Great, all right, looks good.
And last, hold the small end in your mouth and talk.
Testing!
My voice is louder.
It is.
Use a megaphone to make our voices louder, check.
[DING]
Um, Cody?
Yeah.
I need your help in the kitchen.
OK, right behind you.
So talk to me, buddy-bud.
Every time I try to make them, it doesn't work.
Oh, why don't you show me your sequence.
OK.
First, pour the juice into the tray.
OK, looking good.
Next, add the stick.
Hm, look at that, just falls right over.
Yeah, but in the picture, they stand straight up.
Right, well, looks like we've got to debug.
That means find and fix the problem, right?
Yeah.
So the sticks keep falling over in the juice, huh?
Well, we need something to hold them up.
But what?
Oh, hey, you have any plastic wrap?
Always.
OK, then, new sequence, first, pour the juice into the trays.
I already did that.
Yeah, you did.
Next, cover the tray with plastic wrap.
Covering.
Mm-hm, next, add the sticks.
Hm.
The plastic makes the sticks stand up.
Yeah, look at that.
Now add the rest of the sticks, buddy bud.
Na-na!
Mm-hm.
OK, then, put the tray in the freezer.
OK.
Got this.
Mm-hm, don't spill. don't spill.
You got this.
Don't spill.
Don't spill, don't spill.
You got this, you got this.
You got it, you got it.
Don't spill, don't spill.
Got it, got it, you got it.
All right, and last, we wait for the freeze pops to freeze.
Hm.
What do we do while we wait? (WHISPERING) I
have a hard time waiting.
Hm, well, what if we make camel noises?
Well, what does a camel sound like?
Like this [CAMEL NOISE].
[CAMEL NOISE]
Hm, well, we've been doing that a while.
Let's take the freeze pops, huh?
OK.
They're done.
Wow, make freeze pops, check.
[DING]
Cody, Scatter, I did my job.
Follow me.
I found a way to keep the freeze pops cold.
Yeah?
We can put them in here.
[SQUEAK]
Oh--
Hello, penguin.
It is very cold.
Oh, Heart, I am so sorry.
My instructions were not clear enough.
They were not?
Mm-mm, no.
Heart, we need to keep the freeze pops cold when we take
them outside to the neighbors.
Oh, like a cooler?
Oh, yeah.
I have a cooler!
Yeah?
Oh, fantastic.
But it is full of snow.
This is so great, Heart.
We can use the snow to keep the freeze pops cold.
Oh, yeah.
Find a way to keep the freeze pops cold, check.
[DING]
All the jobs are done.
Mm.
[DING]
Oh, it's so hot.
Don't worry, Felix will be here with freeze pops soon.
I'm telling you, no, he won't.
He's going to his brother's reunion.
Frozen freeze pops!
Huh?
That sounds like the Helpsters!
Come on, let's go.
Let's go.
Oh.
Get your frozen freeze pops here.
Freeze pops!
Freeze pops?
Here you go, try these.
Oh, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
Here you go.
Oh.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Hope you like those.
Much cooler.
Mm, much cooler.
Thanks for your help, Helpsters.
You're very welcome.
We did it, everybody.
(IN UNISON) Yeah, we did.